okay [ __ ] is that what if I came back a
lot of crazy stuff check in at reception
so if you guys don't follow like Tim
option l I want my vacation you know
like okay I was such a good like cop
that they gave me a vacation okay so um
you know just enjoying it you know huh
sir ecology said somebody's gotta shave
me good shape shape you all come Thanks
Oh his back is Mac sorry this is fire
down here God good as a piggy learnt sir
yea it's going on here you know you
should totally go check out the beach
okay oh my god you should totally go
cool okay um alright what is this how
about hold up ok I'm back I'm back um
hello sir um I'm good a little stressed
I guess not later recycle Wow alright
that's fine I guess let's check out the
beach and a lot of people are saying
like yeah why don't you do the main
thing I think it cuz it got a little too
fast if we just keep jumping there's so
much to explore you know I'm on vacation
you know there's different shits like
what am I talking about ah steck gut
good
I lost starfish a lot like that pudding
okay so glad they chlorinated the ocean
it features work records yeah yeah same
thing what are you down sir oh sorry
ma'am and it says shells it says police
smoke here okay so I the fine nice
little rocks here you know um surfing I
like surfing you know um yeah what is it
a crap hello cab hello hey kind of kid
kind of kid okay um what is a turtle oh
oh it scared me to ninja turtle
to forget it
for them and that can i buy the bathroom
from the following us on my heart and if
you all right sign
well I came you so fast in the water
okay see this guy's to say hello sir
it's got lost in line or something yo
how's it going I can't get out I found
these shades on like a dead body whoa
where'd you get a crazy hand from to
that was natomas tubular what the [ __ ]
is nana a peeler what is wrong with
people these days get off this Beach
what a waste of time okay I wish someone
time was your time and it says here it's
not always a time it's the instrument oh
oh oh oh you've got fam good good see
there anything else out here all right
what is this tape return
oh wow anything else out here just check
in to check in may I can find my wife
you know he's it go for a while to get
cigarettes and I like hit three years
but I mean I can know what happened
maybe there's something okay and we'll
checking us out I'm doing the z
formation now if you were seeing that
okay okay okay nothing nothing you know
oh oh ah pirate treasure yet hello okay
what the [ __ ]
okay now there's still some more
treasure out here maybe it's over these
areas yeah I'm is it a bird what is that
noise okay i'm at 46 46 checking over
here okay so nany nany all worried nany
all worried checking out is hard to
reach areas in otsuka oh okk good okay
there's one more one more check over
here and we'll check the right here yet
should we check along the water you know
nothing here maybe around here
like I'm looking for treasure nice boats
here nice boats here okay HIV here oh oh
it's around here okay oh wow thank you
thank you thank you okay okay um so
that's good that's good now okay and you
drop that little thing I'm a little
cheat met so that's four main that's not
for you guys it's mine and now we're
going back I just love the zips up ours
would have a foot jump in here I can
yeah hello [ __ ] is this oh oh [ __ ]
the secret ship enjoy enjoy Oh what the
[ __ ] is going on here this is little
horrifying that's all right I'm used to
horrifying oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] but yeah
[ __ ] pizza shadows oh it's Pizza land
there's me two trees god raises pizza
cutter get out of here
uh-uh [ __ ] you potty oh I will not be a
slave to pizza I'm in charge of my
weight oh [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
suck my dick suck my greg dick oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] let me just check my
shirt nothing back here not just more
pizza just more pizza oh shut shut ok ok
I'm in here can I close this I i know
there's Pizza guys here look buck ok ok
I'll pizza and no pizza a pizza oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
oh no I'm saying that the pizza oh [ __ ]
this is a dream oh [ __ ] why'd your honey
okay I boyfriend Johnny in the wall get
them out of there Freehan to me I'll
save oh I'll save him I need one of
those uh those things again I'll get him
okay [ __ ] Chuck they got my god okay
here lady here good [ __ ] dead okay
that's fine I guess okay one time off
this yeah at my way [ __ ] my god did you
[ __ ] die oh sorry guys
no you come back seats meet Selena nope
mukesh [ __ ] i got here and while those
gently citizenship ali loser here [ __ ]
okay the mughal chicken unfortunately
they didn't watch the cannonsburg mi LAN
pool and they be able to hit my note
hello sweetheart the chi è packers are
we bought the cable television doesn't
wobble bethey thank you ding ding ding
oh haha sorry to keep you waiting for oh
thank you thank you Oh what the [ __ ] I
think here is if you get the opportunity
sign into it ok good good now what's bad
there's something doesn't feel right
what are you looking at back there I
want to get behind the scenes wait
that's the cocktail lounge [ __ ] it print
out you know other Oh check out my room
uh-huh sir Oh Michael America I'm think
about your propensity for falling hair
real flower shall we say I'm from where
Abel's at caitlin's tropical pratices a
box of vegetation what do you be so kind
as to assist me and one of my so I que
ella faster it'll be you can he take
anything
it's chatter if we throw our to go to
wake up trouble reasons why are you
fooling who are dating Charles jacket
here sigh here I don't know why that'll
have my legal counsel [ __ ] to you into
my will for Fargo woman my Cayman Island
the stairs she's as I'm indeed as you no
doubt some artists okay for [ __ ] good
good good yeah that's good i'm glad and
what um how that's working out for you
[ __ ] what was my thing about four or
five huh sir what is this 40404 a fire
right here very nice that's okay oh fo
sho where is it or is it oh banana fad
sorry but I've trying to plans that
really mr. McManus art party room
opportunity to pass up uncle rather the
duplicate about high pace so just try to
win swept the prices get the bathroom
you have to trust you all over to get
close enough all over the dials are
feeling a little crawfish look for the
mountain glasses [ __ ] island peligro
that's your bak happening watch [ __ ]
hey who's watching me hey [ __ ] is
watching ray anything get here what is
that oh yay ah shut it kind of sick here
getting kind of sick here what's in here
oh [ __ ] this one is like really bouncy
oh [ __ ] okay job okay cut cake good
anything else entertaining here let's
say let's say you get the bathroom I get
all gussied up a good cut good oh and
lipstick okay okay yes a beautiful
please kiss me okay I hello beautiful
okay Oh chef I'm dizzy I'm dizzy okay
I'm out of here look at all these doors
you know Oh what is this
sexy what [ __ ] you got your [ __ ] dad
is here and see the pics on the balcony
oh okay I'm gonna use up all their
quarters what's in here anyone in here
that's what I do that's my signature
mark took dick my signature mark is to
just kiss the kiss things in the
bathroom Oh what is that the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] pie
for your building heroes are the powder
room you are problem yes yes yes
anything get in here now Oh Jason that's
what I see in the Sun let this one ah
come baby come baby
let's see what game it requesting their
sizes oh [ __ ] we'll go to wooden quick
oh shat formed here's that [ __ ] over
there is that I need a weapon I need a
weapon [ __ ] what is that [ __ ] all y'all
okay god dad yet I'm gonna do this I
think is right you know [ __ ] head I want
your [ __ ] it's like a one shot kill walk
okay okay I'm getting the [ __ ] out of
here the [ __ ] is that as a little
[ __ ] weird it's my room no
nothing in here but I'm beautiful so it
don't really matter nothing that's my
room nothin take it to another floor
who's that what the [ __ ] okay okay and
now this another what is this what
welcome what no no no okay okay let's
see here pull disgusting pulls under me
and that's okay doesn't really can't get
in there okay okay now let's see we got
through here where's that wet bar can I
get up there no here's this guy tumblr
forever my lil more treatable okay I
don't you okay oh [ __ ] why is not like
shaking like a [ __ ] drug addict
work work work work work Rihanna oh oh
[ __ ] hey I'm getting good at this what
the [ __ ] I would beat the show quick yes
I hit it like a little early I get
nothing is this okay I'm not allowed to
surface humans I'm gonna try to [ __ ] is
that yeah well [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
why are there so many games in this game
right [ __ ] you park [ __ ] you oh you like
that like that this is how I play games
okay listen yeah combo bets combo [ __ ]
ya bez perfect yeah okay how's all weird
but I'm fine with that okay let's get
back to the mission where is this [ __ ]
I got to seduce him oh I think yeah i'll
tell you--uh-uh ab something good again
it's not him hope you like to meet later
weird Russian Allah hotel room Miller
yeah yeah we were had a good fondue okay
we're treading very cute I would bang
her ten on ten times horned rimmed
glasses not him hope you all was talking
to Oliver will directional my hotel room
number me Carol and see stars right
I am absolutely distracted by a radiance
allow me to introduce myself I am known
as the editor oh okay huh huh Oh gilfer
the pic to us compliments of the lady in
red oh thank you I swear I would marry
you if I want such a playboy eyeliner
you the money as soon as i receive
shipping i just love your lipstick where
did you get it who does her hair oh my
god i love the shoes the cocktails yes
you let me kiss you kiss your mom kisses
you like I'm getting a [ __ ] drug here
though now what am I supposed to do oh
[ __ ] the lady in red [ __ ] poisoned me
what's the matter of holy blank or dying
old I'm oh yeah I newaz get a little
busy Jess gasps I [ __ ] hate jazz oh
well this is not gonna end go that's all
I gotta say oh all right
oh great I saying this in a poor now
like 10 times I've seen so many pornos
start like this was that potato okay
[ __ ] gross oh [ __ ] this is not gonna
end well for me so what is that semen a
lot of semen here I don't have anything
I did all my show tourists in the
stockyard you are in terminal peril I
want to help come to the rear pool
verify your not chatted oh I see him one
else going on here who is that psycho